time for you to chill out hey zendaya
you are one of the most popular stars
from the Disney Channel we can't believe
that you started acting on shake it up
back in 2013 Disney Channel may have
given you the start of your fame but you
have gone on to be a super successful
actress you've starred in the spider-man
movies from MCU and acted alongside Hugh
Jackman in the greatest showman it's no
wonder you've got a huge net worth have
you ever wondered which Disney Channel
stars are the wealthiest you won't
believe how much one former actress
turned singer is worth keep watching to
see the net worths of 15 Disney Channel
stars
Emily Osmond
you probably remember Emily Osment as
Hannah Montana's BFF Lily Emily comes
from a famous family
her brother Haley Joel was the star of
The Sixth Sense Emily has continued
acting on various TV shows and she has
voiced Ruth on Family Guy since 2012
Emily's net worth is currently around 3
million dollars David Henry David Henry
is probably best known for his role as
Justin Russo on Wizards of Waverly Place
David had been acting for a while before
he started on the Disney Channel he has
acted in several movies including paul
blart mall cop 2 just like emily david
is worth three million dollars Rowan
Blanchard next up is the more recent
Disney Channel star Rowan Blanchard is
best known as Riley Matthews in Girl
Meets World
he also played Jackie on the Goldbergs
Rowan has made a name for herself as a
social activist she isn't afraid to
fight for justice
recently Rowan starred in the 2019 film
a world away Rowan's net worth is
currently 3.5 million dollars debby ryan
the star of Jesse got started on the
Disney Channel way back in 2007 on a
show called yay me starring london
tipton she reprised her character on the
suite life on deck before getting her
own show debbie is now making a name for
herself as the star of insatiable she is
worth 4 million dollars Bella Thorne the
shake it up alum is doing pretty well
for herself these days Bella Thorne just
turned 22 and she has stayed busy she
has several movies and TV shows come
in the next couple of years she has also
become a successful singer Bella's net
worth is five million dollars zendaya
Bella's shake it up co-star has a lot in
common with her zendaya went on to star
in kc undercover she has appeared in
blockbuster movies like the greatest
showman and spider-man far from home
she's also the star of the HBO series
eforea just like Bella's and Diaz worth
five million dollars Vanessa Hudgens
back in 2006 a Disney Channel movie
became a worldwide phenomenon High
School Musical gave us several new stars
and went on to have two sequels Vanessa
Hudgens played Zac Efron's love interest
and they dated in real life she has
continued doing some acting and singing
vanessa is worth 14 million dollars this
Braus twins it's hard to believe that
these twins starred in The Suite Life of
Zack and Cody
way back in 2005 Kol now acts in the
series Riverdale Dillon took a break
from acting but has started doing some
small projects again combined these
twins are worth 16 million dollars Zac
Efron the Disney Channel heartthrob from
high school musical has become a highly
successful actor he has starred in a ton
of huge hits including the greatest
showman and the Baywatch movie Zac Efron
can definitely trace his fame back to
his time as Troy Bolton on the Disney
Channel
I know I promised I'd do this he is
worth 24 million dollars
Hilary Duff ask any millennial and
they'll tell you how popular Hilary Duff
was back in the early 2000s she was the
star of the famous show Lizzie McGuire
which is getting a reboot in 2020 Hilary
continued to do a little acting and
singing she is also the mom of a son and
daughter which keeps her super busy
Hilary is worth twenty five million
dollars Demi Lovato Demi Lovato got her
Disney Channel start on Camp Rock in
2008 she went on to get her own show
sunny with a chance but since she has
left the Disney Channel Demi has focused
her efforts on singing she is a super
successful musician who is regularly
releasing hit songs Demi has earned
every bit of the thirty-three million
dollars she is worth Raven Symone
raven-symoné started acting when she was
really little on The Cosby Show her
Disney Channel series that So Raven was
one of the most popular ever she was
also one of the Cheetah Girls as an
adult
Raven hosted the view she is now the
star of Ravens home Raven Symone is
worth a whopping 55 million dollars
Jonas Brothers the Jonas Brothers became
an overnight sensation for the Disney
Channel these three talented brothers
first appeared on Hannah Montana and
they got their own movie with camp Rock
and a TV show called Jonas these three
are worth about twenty five million
dollars each giving them a combined net
worth of 75 million Selena Gomez Selena
Gomez is another Disney tail star who
has made her fortune from music she got
her Disney start on Wizards of Waverly
Place she has done a little acting since
then but she has become one incredible
musician Selena is worth 75 million
dollars Miley Cyrus no matter your
opinion Oh Miley Cyrus you can't deny
that she is successful the Hannah
Montana star is nothing like she was on
Disney Channel she has built an empire
as a singer and songwriter Miley is
their richest Disney Channel alum with a
net worth of 160 million dollars what
would you do with 160 million dollars
let us know in the comments thanks for
tuning in liked this video and hit the
subscribe button for more great content
we'll see you next time
on the things
[Music]